the story of Despicable Me 3 was a much
tougher nut to crack for a screenwriters
than the first two films in the
franchise which means that there are a
number of scenes that wound up being
deleted and several concepts that ended
up rejected from the final version of
illuminations latest animated movie
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to reveal
and explain some of the scenes and ideas
that were cut from the theatrical
release of Despicable Me 3 I've also got
several sets of awesome merchandise from
the movie to give away for a chance to
win make sure you subscribe and turn on
your notifications and answer the
question I'll be asking later in the
video
a quick reminder there are some spoilers
in this video so take care if you
haven't seen the movie yet Despicable Me
3 screenwriters Cinco Paul and Ken Dario
have said they had trouble finding the
right role for Lucy in this movie
indeed in early drafts of the script
Lucy's role was going to be very
different to what we see in the final
movie originally once GRU and his family
arrived in Fredonia Lucy was going to
start fighting crime there actually if
you think about it this storyline would
have fit in rather nicely with how
Lucy's character was first established
in Despicable Me 2 where she was an
undercover agent for the anti-villain
league and obviously enjoyed her job
fighting crime so it makes sense she
would miss that part of her life when
she and gruha fired from the AVL in this
movie and given the way that Lucy used
various gadgets including a tranquilizer
gun and lipstick taser in the second
film I can't help but wonder what new
gadget she would have used in her
crime-fighting Despicable Me 3 if the
filmmakers had gone ahead with that
storyline what we do know though is that
during the movies cheese festival in
Freedonia there was a big scene cut that
would have featured Lucy chasing after a
robber who's stolen an old woman's purse
as you can imagine from the kind of
humour we see in the despicable Me
movies this deleted scene was full of
slapstick moments as well as
cheese-based puns and sight gags for
instance Lucy was going to have to dodge
a whole load of statues made of cheese
and other cheesy stuff along the way as
she raced after the purse-snatcher and
when she finally caught him she was
going to tell him that this is nacho day
in the end though the screenwriters
decided Lucy's vigilante storyline was
too disconnected from the rest of the
movie and they wanted her story to have
more of an emotional payoff this time so
they focused their attention on building
up Lucy's
nation ship with Margo Edith and Agnes
and how she deals with becoming their
stepmom in fact that decision meant that
Lucy's storyline in this film took a
similar path to grooves in the first
Despicable Me movie as both Lucy and GRU
faced challenges becoming apparent to
the girls but ended up becoming close to
them and later saved their lives after
they're kidnapped by the movies villain
despite all that I think I still would
have preferred the more active and
action-packed crime-fighting storyline
for Lucy in this movie although former
child star Balthazar Bratz is very
clearly the new big bad who team GRU has
to defeat and Despicable Me 3 the
filmmakers didn't always have Bratz in
mind to be their movies number one
villain you see one of the first ideas
for the movie was that brat was just a
henchman to another big super villain he
was the main focus of the film however
that original super villain was pretty
humorless and just didn't work for the
movie because as Despicable Me 3
producer Chris Mallard andriy has said
you need to give GRU a worthy adversary
someone who presents a real challenge as
well as someone who is worthy comedic
Lee Grimm is so fun and lively that if
you put a very straight villain against
him that character will just disappear
fortunately when the filmmakers saw the
animators early sketches of beltasar
brats they realized that his character
had a lot more potential than they first
thought and that he was actually the
worthy adversary for GRU that they'd
been looking for
so they upgraded brats role from a mere
sidekick to a 1980s obsessed super
villain out to destroy Hollywood
speaking of Balthasar brats fixation
with all things 1980s of course that
means the movie contains a ton of
pop-culture references to fashion TV
shows movies and music from that decade
but it's not everything the screen ride
has had in mind to show off brats 80's
mania made it into the final cut of the
film
for example Trey Parker who provides the
voice of Balthazar brat and is best
known as co-creator and star of South
Park recorded a bunch of songs for used
in the movie including karma chameleon a
classic song from 1983 by the British
band culture club
however those songs ended up on the
cutting room floor when the scene where
Bratz was going to sing a track from the
1980s was completely dropped from the
movie however we do still get to hear
voice actor Trey Parker sing in the
movie but now it's a new track called
hug me which was written by Pharrell
Williams
by the way I've made a separate
video about all the cool Easter eggs and
movie references in Despicable Me 3 and
there's a link to that in the video
description below and at the end of this
video
long-lost twin brothers grew and drew
our opposites in many ways and their
contrasting personalities influenced the
filmmakers design of drew in fact Drew's
luck in the final film including his
flowing blond hair and white suit versus
Gru's bald head and dark clothes was one
of co-director Eric Yeon's first designs
for drew however before the filmmakers
finally decided on that particular look
for grooves new brother
they tried out a variety of other looks
including having drew wear a big fur
coat over a sweatshirt a design which
emphasized that drew was both very
laid-back and very wealthy thanks to
having inherited his father's enormous
fortune and pig farm in the end though
that look was rejected in favor of their
first design which the filmmakers felt
reflected Drew's personality and a much
simpler and clearer way the clear-cut
differences between the newly reunited
twin brothers are played up during a
family dinner scene which was also the
subject of several cuts this scene were
grew and drew swapped clothes and
hairstyles and generally clown around
pretending to be each other started out
quite a bit longer than the scene we see
in the final film with the brothers
back-and-forth banter initially
stretching out to over three minutes the
scene was actually rather complicated a
Steve Carell who voices grew and drew
had to play each character imitating the
other character in a conversation
between themselves so to make it easier
Carell recorded all grieves lines first
they went back and recorded all Drew's
lines later
there's also another funny moment that
takes place at Drew's mansion in
Freedonia which was cut from the final
movie in the deleted scene grew and drew
are wearing their new spy costumes and
are examining one of Drew's many weapons
when suddenly Lucy walks in on them in
his pretty annoyed as she thinks they're
now both going to be villains no you too
are villains
ah I mean hello speedy
although this scene ended up being
deleted it looks like there's a little
trace of what the filmmakers were going
for with this moment in the final film
just after Lucy sends away Niko's mother
for cursing Margo she walks towards the
window in Drew's mansion and spots GRU
and drew in their spy costumes jetting
off in their speedboat Lucy looks pretty
annoyed like she knows something is
going on and thinks the brothers are up
to no good which likely relates back to
that deleted scene where she discovered
GRU and drew in their lair now what do
you think about the deleted scenes and
rejected concepts and would you like to
have seen them in the movie I'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
for a chance to win this awesome
Despicable Me 3 merchandise be sure to
subscribe and leave a comment about the
movie and also answer the following
question what was the name of the song
Balthazar Pratt was going to sing that
got cut from the movie make sure you
turn on your notifications to get all my
new videos where I'll be announcing the
winners of the giveaway and let me know
what movie deleted scenes you'd like me
to do in a future video if you enjoyed
this I really appreciate you hitting
that thumbs up button and check out some
more of my deleted scenes and animation
videos right here congratulations to the
first winner of my cars 3 giveaway who's
on the screen now if that's you send me
a message on YouTube or via my email on
my about page so I can get your details
to send you the prize thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippie Kay movie lovers